yes I loo hi if you are from a prime
minister after may the seventh what will
the budget deficit be in pounds at the
end of five years and how will you
achieve it so 75 billion we're going to
inherit we want to balance the books by
the end of the Parliament and we'll cut
the deficit every year and we're going
to do it you by doing three things first
of all we'll have their taxes we're
going to reverse the change that David
Cameron made cutting taxes for those
earning over 150,000 a year secondly
there will have to be spending
reductions in areas outside some
priorities like health and education
because we do need to get the deficit
down and I'll make no bones about that
to you that's going to require difficult
decisions but certainly really important
other thing we've got to do why is it
that the Conservatives promised to
eliminate the deficit haven't done so
let's talk about what you two have sure
all our audience remember with me and
burned out I understand that but I want
to draw a lesson because the reason why
that hasn't happened is because living
standards have fallen so tax revenues
have fallen so the key to getting rid of
the deficit is that third element the
tax changes we've announced the spending
reductions but that key third element of
raising living standards if we raise
living standards in this country will
also get the tax revenues in and the
deficit down okay